okay the next today's voicemail at two
one nine two David P which I'm going to
play for you this may be the next
character in David Pakman show callers
I'm calling this person hillbilly
trumpets and I say it with total peace
and love I don't mean it as an offensive
term I I'm just that's that's I played
this voicemail last week during a live
stream when it came in and hillbilly
trumpet was the way that that was the
consensus name for this individual now
before I play it if you want to call in
and leave a voicemail you can do that by
calling two one nine two david p two one
nine two david p this is furious
hillbilly trumpet i present him to you
today
yeah a david pakman you know you think
that it's a damn bad living in the
united states
what trump's gone maybe ah delete it
sucker low pick up your move your ass to
iran so you can kiss their asses what do
you think of that get er done buddy bye
yeah listen i mean okay so this is this
is a very furious angry person who maybe
is not willing to see reason this entire
concept of if you don't like it leave it
actually has a pretty ugly history and
we've talked about that before on the
show we've seen donald trump apply it to
the ethnic minority congress women some
of whom he sees as clearly more loyal to
other countries than the united states
the individuals known as the squad and
it's it's the idea of if you don't like
it leave has a very ugly past and as
I've said before and I will say again
why would I leave if I have ideas for
how things could just get better here
like clearly the the the people who say
hey here's something that's not working
well in the United States here's how it
could work better here's an ideology
that's not good in the United States we
clearly want to live here because we do
right I mean to some extent it is hard
to find a different place to live if you
don't have some kind of a path to
citizenship elsewhere so you can say
some people may be stuck here that's
another issue going through another
country is not as easy as some might
think but we want to improve the country
we live in we are invested in improving
the country so when we talk about let's
improve education when we say let's
elect better people
when we say let's fix money in politics
so that the political system works
better let's do our fair share and maybe
even more to deal with what's going on
to the climate and the environment we do
it because we are invested in improving
things here it's in it it's sort of a
weird quitters mentality to say oh if
you don't like something here go
somewhere else and by the way Iran is
not the place I would go I have no
interest in leave living in a radical
theocracy that that's there's been
nothing I've ever said on this program
that would suggest that's where I would
go interestingly the people that would
better fit in in a religious theocracy
whether it's Saudi Arabia or Iran or
whatever it's the Christian version of
those same people here in the United
States who are mostly on the political
right so there's the additional irony
that actually it is they who might
better fit in of course they think it's
the wrong theocracy they wanted to be a
Christian theocracy rather than an
Islamic one but that that irony seems to
be sort of lost on them we've got a
great bonus show for you today
Judge Judy is supporting a Democratic
candidate and that candidate is Michael
Bloomberg and there's actually some
interesting stuff going on related to
that which I want to talk about the
Trump administration is also rolling
back an Obama era joint employer rule
which a lot of people don't even know
about and it's important and we're going
to dig into that on today's bonus show
and also retired Pope Benedict is what
Benedict Joseph Ratzinger was his pre
Pope name I believe retired Pope
Benedict who's in his 90s now is warning
Pope Francis against relaxing those
priestly celibacy rules which is
actually one of the Pope Francis has
done things that Pope Francis has done
things that I like and things that I
dislike and in the end it's still the
Pope of the Catholic Church relaxing
those priestly celibacy rules actually
would be a really good thing and a Pope
Benedict is against it so we will talk
about that and much more on today's
bonus show two ways to get instant
access number one become a member at
join pakman.com number two become a
patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
either way i will see you on the bonus
show in mere minutes from now in mere
minutes not minutes from now